and now QuakeCon it's the moment you've
been waiting for this time for some doom
eternal let's do it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
thank you all so much just you makes it
haha you're very sweet
your Legends I'll be Keanu you're a
legend works for him not so much for me
I got to tell you because of stuff like
that the time we get with all of you
here at QuakeCon is really a highlight
of the year for our team
you guys are fantastic thank you for
being here for watching online and for
your continued support we have got a ton
to cover on doom eternal but first you
may have heard we are celebrating a very
special milestone this year the 25th
anniversary of doom
that's right we kicked we kicked things
off several months ago with the launch
of the Slayers Club this is an awesome
yeah I know we got some Slayers club
members in the house right very good it
is an awesome hub for everything doom at
Slayers Club calm you have to check it
out for all the latest news information
fun community events activities and a
lot of giveaways you can even see some
great in-game items in Doom eternal for
participating but we're here because
those original games were just so damn
fun right you know we've always said how
inspired we are by the original doom and
doom 2 and that inspiration continues
through our work on doom eternal so what
better way to celebrate the year of Doom
then bring doom doom 2 and doom 3 to
platforms that need more doom let's take
a look
[Applause]
[Applause]
yes Dhoom Dhoom 2 and Dhoom 3 on
PlayStation 4 Xbox one mobile and switch
yep absolutely and those are all
available today yeah we thought it was
about time our console friends had a
chance to rip and tear as well you're
welcome
in fact all of you here at QuakeCon you
get to play all of them on the Nintendo
switch this weekend over in the Bethesda
booth so you definitely want to check
that out absolutely you're gonna love it
but they aren't the only doom games
playable at QuakeCon this year yeah
that's right we brought you our demo of
doom eternal we were honored to win a
ton of III awards and nominations
including best action game so we knew we
had to bring it to quake on for you guys
I got to tell you though we packed a lot
into that demo it only scratches the
surface of what you'll see and do in
doom eternal from the first kill in the
game to the final boss fight you will go
on a journey unlike anything you've
experienced in a doom game before in
fact here's an exclusive look at one of
our favorite new doom demons in Doom
eternal check this out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
that guy he's called the doom hunter and
he's totally awesome and you're gonna
love fighting against him he's it's sick
it is sick definitely and we'll have
even more from the campaign leading up
to our launch on November 22nd but we
want to talk about the totally new
online experience for doom eternal
battle mode
absolutely you know from the very
beginning our vision has been to create
an engaging and competitive multiplayer
mode that has varied pacing tons of
drama and deep strategy and we had to
look no further than the single-player
campaign to find all the ingredients we
needed battle mode is built from the
same doom combat DNA that you know and
love where skill and power of one fully
loaded Slayer takes on the teamwork of
two player controlled demons and I tell
you playing as a demon is a great change
of pace from playing as the Slayer each
playable demon is simple to understand
totally unique and allows for different
play styles and strategies we're going
to take a closer look at a few to start
welcome to doom eternals battle mode
this two versus one multiplayer gives
players the chance to experience the
fast growth of single-player with their
friends with five playable demons and
six unique Maps at launch battle mode is
a whole new way to play doom to start
let's take a closer look at its playable
characters
the revenant one of the most versatile
and agile demons his jetpack and - allow
you to move quickly through the
environment his shoulder-mounted rockets
deliver consistent firepower while his
special attack a targeted rocket barrage
delivers heavy long-range damage
the pain elemental his ability to fly
gives him a bird's-eye view making it
easier to track the Slayer and attack
from the air but that makes him more
vulnerable when he's not using his
rechargeable soul shield the man cubis
big beefy and badass
he's got heavy cannons flamethrowers and
tons of health all of which make him
lethal in a close quarters fight with
the Slayer while he's not the most
mobile demon his smoke bombs can obscure
his position or flush out an elusive
Slayer but Dean's strategy goes beyond
their individual abilities all the
demons in battle mode can swap hazards
that damage the Slayer as well as summon
different combinations of ai-controlled
demons that behave in fight just like
you expect from the campaign
dropping hazards and summoning Dinah's
is controlled to a summoning wheel
allowing you to use these critical tools
quickly when under fire
in battle mode players take control of a
fully loaded Slayer with all his guns
mods and equipment just like in
single-player the Slayer must
aggressively manage not just the demons
in the arena but also their resources
glory kill demons to replenish health
chainsaw to gain ammo and torch demons
to add armor but be aware each demon
player has a slow charging ability to
block those resources for a short time
during the round a perfectly timed
resource block can put the Slayer on the
ropes
thank you
that's a great example of where the
depth of battle modes gameplay and meta
strategies start to go beyond character
fundamentals to create moments of
incredible pacing and drama
let's take a look starting with
something simple like player outlines
demons can always see the Slayer even
through walls but if the Slayer is able
to break line of sight is outline
vanishes each arena has been designed to
allow a clever Slayer to use the
environment to become invisible and then
flank the demons this can change the
pace of a match from a head-to-head
brawl to a game of cat-and-mouse that
leads to a surprise attack and then back
to a brawl
every arena is also designed with two
portals facing each other at opposite
ends that can only be used by the Slayer
as Slayers learn to use the portals to
flank the demons the tactic can be
countered by demon players who drop
hazards or AI demons on the other end
working together is critical for the
demons when alone a player demon doesn't
typically stand a chance against a
slayer with all his weapons and speed so
Slayers try to isolate a demon take it
out and move on to the next the demons
can counter by staying gross and working
together
there are also important strategies for
the Slayer to master in the air the
Slayer is tough to hit and the arena's
have been designed with jump pads and
monkey bars that a Slayer can use to
traverse from one portal to the other
without touching the ground all while
delivering damage to the demon flares of
course the Slayers need for ammo armor
and health bring him back to the ground
so when he lands - chainsaw an enemy for
more ammo demon players can launch a
coordinated attack
one of the most dramatic moments in
every round is when a demon dies once
the Slayer has eliminated one demon a
respawn timer begins and the Slayer has
20 seconds to eliminate the other demon
to win the round if he fails the dead
demon player rejoins the fight with half
health this quickly turns an all-out
battle into a tense game of hide and
seek
rounds are won when either the Slayer is
killed or both player controlled demons
are killed but strategy extends between
rounds as well players choose upgrades
abilities and even super weapons and
later rounds in a best-of-five match if
either side can win just one round they
gain access to power items like player
demons being able to summon the baron of
hell
for Slayers gaining the BFG
[Applause]
so good we can't wait for you to play it
we're so excited about battle mode we
know you want a competitive experience
that's fun and full of drama and we know
you want it to look and feel just like
doom so with five playable demons plus
the fully jacked Slayer competing across
six totally unique maps there's going to
be tons for every player to master and
I'll tell you this is just the beginning
for us after launch
we'll be regularly releasing even more
playable demons and maps of course all
for free yeah you're really gonna you're
gonna like it it's a ton of fun to play
and honestly it takes an incredible team
of people it did to create all of the
stuff that we get to show you up here
we've got a lot of them in the audience
I'd love for them just to stand up real
quick wave a lot of them are wearing
battle mode t-shirts there we go
many of them will be working the doom
demo so if they're wearing about a mo
t-shirt they're probably from it or work
with this at Bethesda so give them a
handshake and thank them they'll really
really appreciate it we really want to
thank all of you for joining us today we
hope you're as excited about doom
eternal and battle mode as we are we
really are and we can't wait for you to
play the play them both when they launch
on November 22nd
yeah but before we go before we go let's
take one last look at the game including
two more playable demons that I think
you're gonna love one of them is the
arch file and the other one is the
Marauder have a great QuakeCon thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Applause]